franck krawczyk bonjour bonjour on est
aux thermes de saint quentin vous êtes
musicien résidence ici mais vous êtes
aussi compositeur vous êtes aussi
instrumentistes vous êtes aussi
enseignant on va parler un petit peu de
deux de ses facettes si on va vous
retrouver tout au long de l'année ou au
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
d'abord qu'est-ce que c'est un artiste
en résidence je pense que j'ai pas
réellement encore de définition mais je
suis quelqu'un qui est impliqué dans un
théâtre dans la vie d'un théâtre d'une
manière plus large que venir faire un
concert venir faire une pièce exiguë
ramé qui s'occupe pendant une année deux
années le plus possible de ce qui se
passe à l'internât théâtre dans la
programmation est aussi dans la relation
et moi je tiens beaucoup avec les gens
qui font vivre le théâtre dit avec le
public aussi puisqu'un al public
oui il y aura aussi je crois c'est grand
juin le choix de coeur qui sera voilà
des coeurs d'amateurs ça c'est la force
planer c'est la force de ce théâtre là
particulièrement que d'avoir réussi à
avoir une politique face et pour ça
d'ailleurs que je n'ai pratiquement je
crois que c'est la première résidence je
me fais et je la fais pas ailleurs pour
ces raisons là parce que c'est un
théâtre g qui s'impliquent dans la
fidélisation en tout cas dans une
relation avec le public qui est beaucoup
plus riche et qui va jusqu'à la
participation puisqu'il fabrique des
coeurs dans les actions scolaires en
allant chercher des enfants dans les pas
que les enfants d'ailleurs des
adolescents est aussi évidemment avec
des adultes qui viennent ici répéter
dans cette salle d'ailleurs et âme dans
cette salle c'est pas dans cette salle
que vous produirez un petit cadeau qui a
pianos de répétitions c'est pas cellules
non mais c'est fabuleux de retrouver ces
gens dans la saison public dans les
concerts c'est à dire qu'effectivement
on s'adresse immédiatement d un public
qui nous connaît tout simplement avec
lequel on veut qu'on travaille toute
l'année
alors votre votre formation c'est
d'abord une formation pianiste non non
la première formation
c'est fou alors non c'est pas maintenant
c'est pas faux parce que c'est une
coquetterie de ma part mais ma première
formation c'est accordéoniste non
vraiment mais au trafic ou non non non
convoqué monsieur bouton et c'est avec
boutons et
pas du tout le piano pas du tout moi
j'ai une passion pour la musique
tout ce que le répertoire musette c'est
mon enfance pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi
c'est venu l'accordéon c'était mon père
était de la région d'ailleurs il était
accordéoniste d'accord et il vivait
comme tous les accordéonistes le
complexe de l'accordéoniste à dire qu'il
a dit mon fils tu ne feras pas
d'accordéon
ah oui tiens du pauvre convoite aura
aucune carrière tu feras rien etc
regarde moi il était plombier en même
temps c'est pas le fameux plombier
polonais ah oui avant qu'on en parle on
en parle avant la furieuse circulaire il
était très complexe et avec ça et
et moi j'étais très admiratif évidemment
de ce côté de ce qui faisait d'eux parce
que c'était vraiment un instrument
tellement l'homme a mis au piano et je
me rendais compte qu'avec ces
instruments qui était si limité à priori
puisque toutes les basses était fait et
c'était un excellent jeu j'ai trouvé
qu'il faisait beaucoup plus de musique
avec 505 avec mon piano
donc j'ai voulu apprendre l'accordéon ce
qui m'a été évidemment interdit donc
vous êtes un hacker des listes contrarié
voire à tanger contrarié alors de
contrarier je n'ai appris en le
regardant en fait bien que je la gardais
joué j'avais pas tellement droit et
comme c'était une époque où les
conservatoires commencé à naître
enfin j'ai pas vieux mais quand même
c'est années 70 75 et les conservatoires
ma mère avait décidé de faire un
conservatoire pas très loin à herblay
donc hr herblay cet accord il était
d'achères lui et donc il n'y avait pas
de place le maire avait dit oui on veut
bien faire un conservatoire mais
vous débrouiller pour les locaux donc
les locaux c'est devenu la cave chez
nous adacore donc famille de musiciens
oui socialement de musiciens qui
essayait de gagner sa vie en faisant
autre chose et gagner pas leur vie de la
musique mais quoi donc je faisais de
j'ai appris en face de lui donc j'ai un
peu comme les dyslexiques je savais plus
qui était la main droite de la main
gauche
j'étais un peu perturbé et puis très
vite c'est devenu un instrument naturel
et j'ai fait à ce moment là pas mal de
balles avec un accord j'ai suivi oui je
suis est rare pour un musicien classique
même si c'est de la musique
contemporaine
sa sert a fait débat mais en fait ça
donne ça apporte quelque chose non
oui bah déjà ça apporte le public
la relation au public là elle vous l'a
payé comptant ouais c'est pas une
relation acquise
les gens sont pas du tout un exemple
sont pas là pour vous flatter oui non et
la prise de parole évidemment est
particulière ça apporte que la musique
n'est pas une chose facile acquise c'est
bien on vous attend pas vous êtes je me
sentais comme un musicien du xviiie
siècle
enfin à l'époque je ne savais pas que
c'était ça mais c'est à dire un musicien
de coûts en fait
et est ce que le fait d'avoir fait je
voulais rejouer pour des balles comme ça
alors que vous êtes un compositeur donc
un compositeur de musique contemporaine
dont on dit parfois c'est une musique un
peu éloigné de lui des gens qui volent à
un peu intellectuel au mais est ce que
ça vous a donné une fibre populaire
justement pas populiste pas pour lui non
mais
mais de faire une musique aux fonds qui
soit accessible non ça m'a donné une
seule et unique chose sais c'est que je
ne m'intéresse réellement musique à que
la chose que j'entends et que je peux
contrôler dans l'oreille c'est à dire ça
m'a donné un pragmatisme reconnaître
qu'ils ont fait à la fin
ce qu on vous pardonne pas dans le
milieu populaire c'est qu'une chose soit
pas entendu ou vécu voilà tout
simplement d'eux qu'ils fassent pas part
d'une expérience vécue
quel ce soir une chanson
vous la pardonne pas si la terreur dans
la sophistication de quelque chose tout
discours tient population est d'accord
et c'est ça que ça m'a fait aller
cherche à aller chercher finalement une
relation plus directe par la musique
même la musique pensée intellectuelle
puisque intellectuelle on est tous
intelligents et ce rien lire non aux
préjugés bien sûr balader sans son
cerveau mais c'est intéressant mais donc
c'est juste de dire la seule chose que
je parte à celle vécue
celui qu'on va dire vrai cette idée
comme ça que la musique dite classique
ne s'est pas toucherez le coeur alors
que la musique contemporaine toucherait
le cerveau c'est un peu cette hydre à
qui ils sont
c'est faux c'est pas moi c'est sais pas
c'est peut être que elodie dans sa fête
à dire que bétonne ou mozart son bar je
vois pas quelque chose de plus pensez
absolument plus construit même je
connais aucune musique contemporaine qui
soit arrivée à la hauteur de cette
pensée formelle alors donc vos études
c'est donc essayer de commandes de
pianiste vient bientôt et après après
oui d'instrumentistes est aussi assez
vite de compositeur oui parce que piano
mais ennuyé très vite je me souviens
je peux vous dire je n'ai jamais fait ça
mais j'ai essayé d'ailleurs de le faire
mais c'est pas évident
monde
et j'ai fait ça je suis sorti pour
concert à 11 ans parce que ça serait
peut-être deux fois je me suis dit on va
dire ce que c'est quand même un
pathétique de beethoven concerto un
concert à l'école normale
un petit concert mais bon c'était une
note difficile vous les invisibles et il
y avait à ce moment là
les gens écoutent ils disent bon quelque
chose et moi je me disais voilà un
moment
où je peux réfléchir ma vie
tu t'en ailles
faut que ça passe a
etc etc
je me dire
kim a tenu d'y rester
alors là je dis maintenant il ya deux
solutions
bien
et je reviens encore au même point ou
bien je m'en vais
à
au revoir je ferme je rentre chez moi je
ne touche pas au piano c'est l'agent
jean louis et c'était très surprenant
parce que j'étais un garçon timide et
c'est dingue que ce soit bête homme qui
m'est donné lui même la force de
d'interrompre un cerf alors ça se
passait très bien et je me suis dit
quand même c'est la musique a une force
folle parce que jamais de moi même je
repris cette autorité là c'était dire
que c'est pas la musique que vous fuyez
à ce moment là c'est le cfai piano la
raddho ayant rapport à l'état de cette
musique là ou non l idée que maintenant
si jamais je dois faire quelque chose je
dois faire quelque chose qui est ma
vision de la musique
d'accord c'est déjà je vais plus jouer
celle des autres veut faire la mienne
c'est dire que c'est là que vous pensez
que vous ne serez pas seulement aux
instrumentistes vous serez aussi un
compositeur et je veux pas être vu comme
ça veut pas être vu comme quelqu'un
singes qui reproduit en plus quand on
est petit on éviterait aux remuants non
ah oui si manière inconvenante
earth est immense et je reviens chez moi
et je demande des crayons des papiers et
j'écris strictement n'importe quoi
d'ailleurs je crois même que j'ai essayé
d'imaginer une suite à ça et j'ai
totalement perdu et puis j'arrive est
rien écrire et puis j'ai écrit schubert
enfin j'ai évidemment commencer par
recopier recopier en copier puis je
voilà et puis après pour continuer de
travailler non un instrument bien ça
m'intéressait vraiment plus lé grand
désespoir de tous avant même ma mère un
peu et puis ma prof surtout kim faillit
y arrive il ça parce que je suppose que
vous étiez plutôt très doux et donc
quand on joue c'est la comprenais pas et
on mallet mais dans ces cas là quand
quelqu'un une forte surtout les enfants
quand tes choix ils ont une forte
détermination on est prudent quand même
j'ai l'impression j'avais le regard un
peu sur moi qui était de dire où l'on
comprend rien de ce qui fait de ce qu'il
dit mais on laisse dont la seule
personne nous a découragés en disant non
personne n'à rien à envier aux pires
doucy dont sa fille nicole après j'ai la
chance d'avoir rencontré des gens
intelligents sais rien j'ai quand même à
l'école normale gt quelques années plus
tard obligé de reprendre le piano pour
avoir le droit d'intégrer une un cours
de composition
ah oui est-ce qu'il fallait que j'aille
quand même alors j'ai été voir votre
travail est vrai il m'a dit je dis
seulement plus du tout aucune capacité
pour rentrer dans une classe de piano
mais je peux faire je peux faire la
faire à n'importe quel moment vous me
demandez de jouer quelque chose pourrait
faire un peu la fête
j'ai dû jouer
donc j'ai dû là j'ai un peu va dire
baver un peu partout j'ai pas fait
bien avec toutes les notes je fais un
geste et m'a dit je te prends mais tu ne
seras pas pianiste s'assommer city serge
petit gérard c'était un moment pour moi
fort parce qu'il m'a reconnu tout ça à
l'école normale à part il m'a dit avant
que je lui dise il m'a dit tu ne feras
pas de piano et il m'a envoyé chez un un
pianiste qui faisait de la musique
contemporaine m'a dit ouah il faut que
tu ailles voir là et là je me suis
retrouvé au milieu d'une classe d'
analyse de ces terres à et ma fille
s'est orientée vraiment pas
j'ai eu des interlocuteurs sur lui j'ai
eu des interlocuteurs sur la composition
et après très très très vite
c'est-à-dire le cette personne m'a
envoyé voir philippe manoury qu'il était
un compositeur qui m'a dit bombages
ouvre une classe de composition à lyon
et je le suis et je rencontre gilbert
amy qui était mon deuxième
enfin mon premier grand grand même et
toujours de musique et je me suis trouvé
comme ça embarquer dans une histoire de
composition pour après que j'aie casting
était quand même votre souhait même si
la formule est enfin c'était salut qu'à
un moment je claque la porte
sa présence dans trois ans et 11 ans et
18 ans parce que vu ma première commande
tout a été vite mais ma première
commande c'était au festival d'automne
89 il y avait 1 vous avez quel âge vous
êtes un virement gte
j'avais 18 ans oui c'est donc 89 non
j'avais 20 ans à ce moment là je
travaillais sur berg et j'ai fait
quelque chose pour claude helffer qui
était donc celui qu'il l'a joué de ma
vie après tout hein tout temps ma vie a
été d'essayer de ne plus composer un bon
alors écouter fort qu'on va on va
s'interrompre et puis on va reparler de
tout ça
dans une autre c'est toujours me rends
compte qu'à chaque fois que je fais un
truc j'essaie de le défaire donc on va
se retrouver merci beaucoup